all four of our living ex presidents say
the killing of George Floyd shows how
America has failed to overcome its
racial divide as that O'Keefe reports
former President Barack Obama brought up
the issue for the very first time on
camera just yesterday we have seen in
the last several weeks last few months
the kinds of epic changes and events in
our country that are as profound as
anything that I've seen in my lifetime
speaking is part of a forum sponsored by
his foundation former President Barack
Obama called for police reform
chokeholds strangleholds just saying
that's not what we do you don't need
that in order to effectively restrain
someone mr. Obama's comments come as his
predecessors are also condemning recent
events in remarkably candid terms former
President George W Bush said he's
anguished by the brutal suffocation of
George Floyd and that it's time for
America to examine our tragic failures
former President Bill Clinton said that
no one deserves to die the way George
Floyd did and the truth is if you're
white in America the chances are you
won't and former President Jimmy Carter
acknowledged his own upbringing in the
segregated south adding we need a
government as good as its people and we
are better than this the status will
always resists without separation in the
town hall he spoke directly to young men
and women of color who he said have
witnessed too much violence and death
too often some of that violence has come
from folks who were supposed to be
serving and protecting you I want you to
know that you matter I want you to know
that your lives matter that your dreams
matter mr. Obama also praised police
officers who have been marching with the
protesters and showing restraint and
acknowledged that there are many police
chiefs out there that are also pushing
for policing policy new policing policy
look historically former presidents try
to stay out of the spotlight after they
leave the White House but in recent
weeks mr. Obama has shown by endorsing
Joe Biden and vying to campaign for him
by speaking out about president Trump's
leadership during the coronavirus and
now this forum on police policy
that he's gonna be a completely
different and much more vocal former
president Gail it appears so ed it was
interesting to see the other president
speak up but President Obama said
yesterday sometimes you have to make
people in power feel uncomfortable and
speak up
it was extraordinary to hear what he had
to say yesterday thank you very much ed